welcome everyone from my side to the
third annual bioprocessing digital event
my name is mark dukop and i'm co-founder
of novasign today i'm going to talk
about
from experiments data hybrid models and
digital twins so it will be
some you will see some use cases from up
and down stream success stories that
will highlight the benefits
of using advanced process modeling so to
give you a little outline about
what you will see basically i will just
quickly introduce nova sign the company
i'm working for
uh the problem we're currently having on
the market and some showcase so an
upstream showcase basically
downstream showcase uh for you what will
you learn today basically
so uh you will understand or i will try
to unders to teach you some of the
the cycle of process modeling uh you
will learn how hybrid models outperform
ordinary purely data driven modeling
and finally i will show you for an
option showcase for example where you
will see how intensified model-based
design of experiments
can significantly help to accelerate bio
process development
good starting with as that i'm working
for nova science we're a young spinoff
from
the university boca university indiana
basically we're currently six employees
and six
people in the board uh we are focusing
on speeding up bio process development
and we were founded or we founded our
company in 2019 and you can see for
example a picture of us in the pilot
facility
of the university uh what we do
basically as i said we are
accelerating bio process development and
we therefore
develop the hybrid modeling toolbox if
you're interested in using this hybrid
modeling toolbox
you can use your smartphone right away
you can
scan this qr code you will be redirected
to a
page where you can then when you have to
register
you can then download this toolbox for
free and use the freemium concept
you can use the free version of the
toolbox forever for free
and if you're interested and you can
also you can also use in the extended
version where where a lot of value comes
in which basically helps you to
accelerate your bio process development
so as that is the hybrid modeling
toolbox
it's there to create time resource
bioprocess models
and it helps you to get a better process
understanding it can be used for process
optimization
it has a digital tweet implementation
inside and you can take this model
afterwards
for a process model like sorry for
real-time control
like a soft sensor but i will show you
this today in the presentation i will go
for that through this
okay good so now when we have to design
a certain problem and we look at the
biopharmaceutical market
there's somehow an issue because when
you look at the timelines
normally new drugs that come to the
market take something between still 10
to 14 years until they reach the market
and when you look at the resources
basically which are spent to do so
you see that a lot of effort is going to
the clinical uh trials basically
and not that much of effort is put into
process development and manufacturing
actually
however when we now look back one year
we see that
sorry this is what i just said you see a
lot of gaps when we now look back
and we look at the coffee benson
vaccines that somehow just entered the
market
you see that everything was extremely
condensed and we saw
all of this happening in one year so
that means
somehow the the comfort times back then
and where process development was not
the main uh
a main issue in the whole development
process somehow changed and
we believe that the pressure on process
development will be even higher in the
future
when we think about that authorities and
also companies get used to
reduced clinical trials so i don't say
that we will see future drugs in one
year on the market but if you think
about
we could reduce this process from 10 to
14 years maybe down to four
you can also think that you have to
shrink all of the process development
resources or the
the timelines also significantly to cope
with this
with new timelines and as a result you
have to somehow change your behavior and
you have to
do things differently in order to
accelerate this
process development also okay
moving forward
we made a survey among 80 pharma experts
so last year so we hosted a vital
conference with siemens cetera and
nova science and we invited 80 pharma
experts and we were asking that
basically what they believe future
timelines
of new drugs will be and the main
finding was basically that most of them
or
the average of them believe that in five
years the average timeline of new drugs
will be three to seven years which would
be a
huge significant increase or decrease in
the in the timeline
and then we were also asking hey if we
think about these timelines what are
basically they're
what are the enablers for that and if
you look at this obviously a lot of
people are believing
that integration of new technology
modeling artificial intelligence
robotics will be one of the main drivers
as an increased process understanding
and an increased
data accessibility and the digital
infrastructures are that they're
basically the main driver
that i believe to significantly
accelerate fire process development
okay now moving into this first learning
of today i think what is very important
to understand is i call it the cycle of
process modeling
maybe also other names for that but if
you think about what you have to do to
create a powerful process model
uh you first of all should think about
experiments i mean this is the basis for
everything
the experiment is a very important thing
but not only the experiments that you
cover some of the critical process
parameter or the critical material
parameters
you also have to think how do you create
the data based on that so and there's
some
there's some important effects that the
data contains basically the information
that that you need for modeling then
afterwards as easy as it sounds
it's often not so easy and i already saw
quite a lot of of problems here so
the thing i want to pitch here is that
it's really important that when we talk
about process modeling it's not only
about the modeling itself but you have
to think about the whole cycle in order
to create the real value
so from the data then the next step is
that you create a model so you have to
have a model by hand
that is suitable to describe what you
actually want and finally
we're talking about digital twin
implementations which then mimic
somehow the physical world so we're then
bringing from this experiment
we're creating data we're building a
model based on that and then we're
transferring this model into the digital
twin environment
where we can then in silico play with
our process and extract much more
information
and if you are then doing this in the
digital twin you can either think about
okay
we uh continue with new experiments so
we iterate further we say okay we're not
happy yet what we got what we got we do
process optimization or we say okay
we're fine with the process model and we
take this process model basically for
manufacturing
and the thing what is really important
is to understand that all of this is
somehow equally important it's not like
a lot of people believe that process
modeling or artificial intelligence
per se will solve everything so you have
to think about the whole thing at once
and performing the right experiment is
equally as important as the as the model
so just having hybrid models by hand or
just having a certain
artificial intelligence by hand will not
will not solely
be the will sort your issue so you
really have to think about the whole
thing at once
it means somehow you should think about
it from the back you have to think about
what
do you want from that from a model what
do you want from the digital twin what
should it
what should it be used for how do i have
to create my model structure what is the
data i need and what other experiments i
have to do if you think about
from the from the back way from when you
think this in a
reverse order then you are really on a
good journey
to create powerful hybrid to create
powerful models or to create a digital
twin that really helps you to better
understand your process
okay having said this uh high level
things now we're going to showcase
and i will highlight i will highlight
how what exactly i just
just talked about on a high level okay
first we have this upstream showcase the
objective here is to find the method
that best describes a certain design
space we want to do this as fast as
possible because as i said we want to
reduce
we want to accelerate the vibros
development and finally we want to use
this model
than for real time control and
monitoring okay
so the use case i want to present you
today is a 20 liter
fat batch cultivation with e coli we're
having three critical process parameters
we're changing the temperature we are
changing the feeding rates and we're
changing the induction strength
all on three levels it means we have a
three-dimensional full factorial design
space of 27 experiments
and if you think about that one of these
experiments takes one week
you can think about that this feeling
this whole design space is half a year
of work
to understand what's really going on
that means this is a lot of time you
have to spend
and therefore you have to do it quite
clever in order
in order to to get ahead fast and to
extract the valuable information
and the response variables we're
modeling today is the biomass
and the soluble product items so these
are the two response variables we're
interested in
good moving forward how can we now
describe a certain design space what
options do we have to
to describe this data you're generating
from your from your bioreactor
so there's basically the the thing that
i see often in industry is the typical
dua endpoint description
uh we can think about nonparametric
modeling or blackbox modeling we can
think about mechanistic modeling or we
can think about
hybrid modeling basically this is what i
will present today most of the time
uh if you now think about a
two-dimensional just as a hypoth or just
as
an example if you think about the
two-dimensional design space
and you want to describe this you can do
your experiments and let's say each of
these each of these
red x's represents an endpoint of your
process
you can think about that you might
believe you understood your process and
you could use these end points for
example
with classical poe toolboxes to somehow
describe what's going on but the thing i
want to what to want to pitch here today
and
i want to challenge is you can think
about for example one of these endpoints
the process towards this might look like
this the process might look like that or
the process might look like this so
and it's quite clear to understand it's
easy to understand that all of these
processes would
have a completely different consequence
basically to your model so if you would
now just create a
typical dv model based on the endpoint
you might be able to describe the data
but
most probably you didn't really
understand what's what's happening in
your process
so i call this the schrodinger's cat
issue or the static dui knowledge gap
and first thing you have to do basically
and as easy as it sounds you have to
somehow sample the response variable
you're interested in over time
and then you have to create a model
that's basically describing this
response variable over time
accurately and then you are you are
a lot of steps further or a lot of stuff
closer to
to your to having a powerful model and
rather as you look at the end point
and for doing so we are basically using
hybrid modeling to describe
time-resolved uh
fire process okay
moving in this direction uh the hybrid
model we're basically using here
uh consists of a black box and
artificial neural networks
which is fed by three inputs the
temperature the feeding rate and
inductor
and basically what we want this this
black box to predict
is the mirror so the specific growth
rate and the specific product formation
rate and these
two rates basically go into the white
box part
and in the white box we couple the
current biomass dx
to the to the specific growth rate at
the time point
and we also consider the dilution rate
so for example if you think about a fat
batch reactor and you feed something in
that also changes uh also changes your
process never if you consider this also
when you take samples out
all of this can be considered also in
this mechanistic part
and finally we're thinking about the
product side where we then couple the
biomass to the specific water
information rate
and this this i here represents um an
inductor switch that means when you
induce your cells this is one and when
you do not induce yourself it's zero
that means in the time where you don't
induce yourself you cannot overestimate
your
your broader information rate and by by
using such an hybrid model such a
combination of the black box in the
white box
you can describe the data basically or
you can describe this design space much
better so what we see here
is the comparison between a purely
data-driven model
and the hybrid model of all of these 27
experiments so each of these dots here
represents a single observation so
taking a sample
from your bioreactor at each time point
you can see the comparison how to build
a
driven model compares to the black box
sorry to the hybrid model
and vice versa so in a and b you see
this in all of the all of the
observations we have
and c in c and d are two two example
runs for example
where you can see the sampling over time
which is depicted by these circles
uh sorry better triangles and basically
you can see how the hybrid model
describes this data and how the black
box describes this data and by that you
can already see that the hybrid model is
much more accurate in describing the
current design space
rather than the pure black box but you
can also look at the end points if you
only want to look at the end points and
you compare now classical tv toolboxes
like jump mode and so on
and you just look at the endpoint you
see when you describe the biomass
the hybrid model does not outperform uh
the the pure black box mod i did the
pure
uh ref respawn surface model at the end
point so we see the error is both in the
range of three percent
but due to the fact that we couple the
biomass to the product
sorry that we coupled the product to the
biomass in the hybrid part we see that
when we describe the product to the
endpoint
already the hybrid model outperforms the
the state-of-the-art
response surface model by far so by a
factor of
it's quite double that double the error
basically yeah so by that i i hope i
could prove or i could show you
that hybrid models are quite a very
powerful tool to
describe data better than better than
pure
black box models for example but the
thing is by now i mean we have now a
tool in hand that can describe the data
quite accurately but we didn't
accelerate anything so far so the next
thing is okay how can we now how can we
do this fast how can we now really
accelerate the process
and here i want to show you something
the comparison between a
classical full factorial design of
experiments so this is for example here
the full factorial design space where we
cover all of the 27 experiments
we can compare this to a fractional
factorial for example where we only take
nine examples
nine experiments or what we can do this
is what i will show you in the next
slide in detail
is is intensified design of experiments
so what you do is basically you
pack several parameter combinations in a
single experiment so what you can see
here
if you look at the blue plane for
example you see a line connecting three
of these parameter combinations
and it this means one of these lines is
one experiment so you start in a corner
or you start with certain
parameter combination and after a
certain time in our case after
one theoretical cell doubling we change
the process conditions
the next parameter combination and so on
and so forth and by doing so
you see that you can pack multiple
experiments uh that you can
pick multiple parameter combinations in
a single experiment so
when we compare the fractional factorial
with the intensified design of
experiments we see that both only
consist of nine experiments
but the intensified design of
experiments uh covers all of the
possible parameter combinations in this
particular case that means you extract
basically everything that's really going
on
and you do not you do not need to avoid
some of these experiments in order to
reduce the amount of
okay and now comparing this in the next
slide what you can see here is basically
this is this is i think one of the most
important things when you think about
intensified design of experiments so
what we see here is we created a hybrid
model
based on ido so this is the orange the
orange dots you see we have 213
observations
from nine runs basically we create a
hybrid model based on that and then we
take this hybrid model
and as test data we take the static
experiment so the normal experiments
where you don't change parameters where
you keep parameters constant for the
whole
for the whole uh process we take as the
test data
these are these 598 observations
basically it is
with the green triangle cell and you can
see how accurately the hybrid model that
is built
only on the intensified trans is able to
predict the static experiment so that
means information is the same
and you could either do the 27
experiments or you can just do the nine
experiments
in order to describe the same data to
describe the same science beta
and in b c and d you can see nine
examples of runs basically
how how the model was able to predict
these static experiments what you see
from that basically you can save a lot
of process time
because you just we just performed nine
experiments in this case it's 31 because
we also did triplicates
of of several points and by doing so you
see that you can save a lot of time but
you still
extract the same information and if you
think about what what
a 20 liter reactor costs you in terms of
resources equipment and manpower
that's quite significant advantage
advantage if you use intensified design
of experiment
but you can also do the same here you
see the same for depicted for the
product
so before it was on the biomass here we
see the same for the product so we see
predictive product over measured product
in a
and in b c and d the same cultivations
basically uh
for the for the product how the product
propagates over time
okay moving forward uh
to understand this better whoops here we
go
you can go into the digital tweet
basically in the digital twin you can
play with your process basically so what
i just
showed you was the comparison of full
factorial and and intensified experiment
intensified science experiments but what
you can also do is you can
justify and intensify this kind of
experiment go into the digital twin
and understand how your process would
react and process changes so like the
digital twin
somehow the in silico representation of
your process and i will show you this in
this
feeding rate and
inductor and you can say when you change
here the
sliders you can see how your process
reacts so we see that the
with the blue one for example is the
biomass and
[Music]
purple one is the product you can see by
changing this process
you see how your process reacts so
basically this in silicon representation
helps you to understand your process
much better and therefore this
these the stitches of green helps a lot
to
better extract information from your
process
okay but what you can also do is you can
use this digital twin uh for two for
process optimization so what you can do
here
basically is uh if you think about an
initial set of experiments
you perform this experiment you create a
hybrid model and then in the hybrid
model or in the digital twin basically
you use process optimization or a lookup
table and
you simulate some infiligrants and say
okay what is my perfect run what is my
best run in order to optimize
to maximize for example the product then
the digital twin tells you okay which
which of this cultivation is it then you
can perform this cultivation in real
time or
just afterwards you take this
information or you take the data you put
it back
into into the data set you create a new
hybrid model and you iterate further so
you can either say okay are you already
satisfied do you find it found an
optimum and after next iteration there's
no other optimum
or do you repeat it basically or do you
use it for example for
for process control so what do you how
do you how do you progress
afterwards and i can show you the
example here
in this case uh we are interested in
space-time yields so we want to optimize
the space time yield
and we see here for example five
questivations with certain parameter
combinations
we create a hybrid model we put the
hybrid model into the digital between
and in the digital twin we say okay now
give me a suggestion what is the best
where's the optimum in my design space
what performance what experiments do i
have to perform next yeah
okay the digital twin suggests an
optimum and the optimum would look like
this so basically
the digital twin says okay if you if you
do it that way you get this space time
yield and this is how likely
your your new experiment would look like
okay then you basically perform this
experiment
you can confirm how this experiment fits
to your predictive model
and then you take this data of this
experiment and put it back
and create basically a new model and
this new model for sure
describes this data more accurately and
then you go to the next step and say
okay are you already satisfied
or do you do you enter the loop again
and go ahead go ahead and go ahead
in order to find the or to find the
maximum at the
optimum okay
i said either further optimization or
you can use this model for control
and when i talk about use this model for
control this is basically something i
want to show you next is a collaboration
with siemens basically
where we created the soft sensor
together so what you see here is the the
living lab of siemens in vienna you see
a bioreactor there in the back
and what was what happened back then is
that uh cements performed
an uh design of experiment run by
changing ph and temperature
they gave us the data we created a
hybrid model based on that
in our toolbox we are able to export or
to pack this hybrid model into a certain
structure
the dll file so we put this structure we
put this dll file back to
siemens siemens integrated this dll file
into the cyborg environment
and was done able to do a soft sensing
or real-time control or monitoring as
you want to call it
during the cultivation and this is what
you can see here so basically
you see the blue line is this nervous
and soft sensor
you see the offline measurements in this
case we're talking about biomass soft
sensing
we have the offline measurements which
are the uh
at the red x's and what you can also see
is the the office measurement during
this cultivation you can see how
precisely this uh
soft sensor is able to predict the
current biomass during your cultivation
so you could use such about such a soft
sensor for example to find
ideal time point of induction or uh if
you want to transfect cells or if you
want to harvest cells if you want to
terminate cultivation at a certain
maximum concentration of biomass
whatsoever so you could this is this is
a typical application of such a such a
soft sensor
and what they also did is they changed
the medium so what you can see here
basically is
another cultivation with a different
medium media and you can still see that
it worked out quite
okay so finally concluding this upstream
showcase uh i hope i could show you that
the hybrid model bridge the gap between
mechanistic understanding and
data insights uh we can use this hybrid
model to best describe critical process
parameters how these critical process
parameters interfere with the critical
quality attributes or what you want or
the target parameters
i could show that the hybrid mod is
better suited to describe certain data
than the black box modeling
they intensify design of experiments and
the model based design of experiments
both at in
to significantly accelerate the process
characterization process optimization so
by reducing the experiments you have to
perform
and finally you can use this model to
export it into a scada or ama system for
real-time monitoring okay this was an
upstream showcase
now i want to show you a downstream
showcase so in a downstream showcase
division we're talking here about tff so
targeting concentration
and what we want to do is we want to
understand how a certain membrane
and a certain product interact with each
other and we want to do a minimum
set of training experiments and to use
these training experiments to predict
somehow
how a process could be set up so so it's
from the perspective of you want to from
the process engineering perspective
you want to understand how input and
output is connected to each other
and you want to optimize your process
basically on a minimum set of
experiments so in order to do so you
have to think about
if you think again and this at this
circle of process modeling you have to
think about what are the experiments i
have to perform
what are the factors i have to vary
how does the data has to look like and
then how is the model
to look like in order to be able to do
so and this is what i will show you next
so
with a clever model training you can
then
with this model be able to predict the
duration of the batch tff of a fat batch
tff you could also
predict single tangential single pass
digital profile
and also dia filtration this is what i
will show you in the next five minutes
basically
but the cool thing is that you don't
have to change your behavior so you
don't have to change uh your operator
behavior you can do ordinary things tmp
excursion and this is for example
something you would get from such a tmp
excursion you would get basically
a flag stator over protein concentration
or flux data over tmp
and this is the data you would get from
such a such a training experiment
moving further with such with such data
what we want to do is we want to create
a hybrid model
and i said it's important to think about
the important parameters
the import parameters here are basically
the pmp
the cross flow so the the the the gross
flow which is driven by the pump
and the basic the concentration of the
of the
of the of your target you're interested
in then we put this into a black box
this black box predicts as a flux at
each parameter combination
and then we go into a mechanistic mass
balance and say okay this flex is
constant for three seconds we subtract
this from the current volume
and then we get a new concentration and
then we take this new concentration
put it back into the black box from the
beginning and we get a multi-step ahead
hybrid one so by doing so
we could basically predict the duration
of the process
already at the beginning so if we said
this is the parameters we keep or we
want to have for our
for our for our tfs process we already
know when the process is over
and this is basically what you would see
here so here then when you look at the
test data
what we performed here for five
different experiments at five different
concentrations so you see there's quite
a huge spread
in the the initial flux
basically driven by the by the starting
concentration
and you can see how the hybrid model how
accurate the hybrid model basically
predicts the duration
compared to how long the experiment
performed
in real you can see these normalized
rhythmic square errors are all in the
range of
below six percent i would say so that's
quite helpful
but the really the beauty of this is
that the flux prediction
and the test so the the training set and
the test that are completely independent
so they
they are completely different and that
means basically
that you uh did you see that the value
of this hybrid model comes that
the test data just is completely
different from how you would have
trained your model that means
in in order to create clever models this
hybrid model helps a lot
because you don't have to perform a lot
of different experiments you can come
with a very limited training data set
and you're still able to to predict the
duration of such a process
and the next beauty is when you think
about fat batch tffs what fat batch dfs
means you have a search tank so you
sorry you have
you have your concentration tank but
unluckily your concentration tank is not
large enough for the whole volume you
have to process that means you have a
certain search tank
and once you concentrate in that means
that the volume
of your of your of your of your
recirculation tank somehow decreases
and this fail is filled up again from
the search tank so somehow it's it's
like
dire filtration but you are not you're
not changing the buffer you're just
filling up with with fresh protein
solution
and the beauty of this hybrid model is
you can also be able to model this you
just have to change basically the white
box or the mass balance in order
to still be able to also predict or to
perform to perform
the duration predictions with this with
this fat patch dff
and you can see this basically in this
graph here
you can see how accurately the hybrid
model was able to predict the duration
also for three different test data sets
where we had a rather small
recirculation tank and a large search
tank a different concentration
and the model was not trained
differently so we still have the same
model trained on the single data set
but we are able to predict different
different outcomes
okay good now i want to show you this
basically in the digital twin
environment again
so what you see here to the right are
four factors you see the or the yellow
one is basically the concentration
you're looking at
we have the the the batch tank volume
which is the blue one
and the purple one i would say is the
flux or the
or the purple something i don't know
this color
the the color to the right okay what you
can see now
with with the slider
you can see how how for example the
change in the tmp or the change in the
feed flow or the
the change in the concentration start
concentration change the duration of
your process so the y-axis or the x-axis
here is the time basically
and you can also see how for example if
you do fat batch or
batch you see how this is how this
change is completely approached and this
is i said all in silico so you
just have this one training data set you
use to set up this
and then you can you can basically
define your process in silico
with a minimum set of experiments this
is it saves you a lot of time and
resources okay moving to the last point
i want to make here is the
single path enterpro filtration with the
same training data set you're also able
to predict single
fast energy filtration in in serial mode
or in parallel mode as you can imagine
the only thing you have to change
somehow
is a little bit the white box part so
by doing so what we see here basically
so we trained the hybrid model on a
single training data set and you were
able to predict
the volumetric conversion factor
for a single membrane for two membranes
and for three membranes basically
at different different heat pressures
and you don't have to perform these
experiments at the beauty so you see the
the circles basically are the real
experiments
and the lines are the model and all of
these experiments uh
were just done to confirm them all but
at the end you don't have to do it you
can
understand your process in silico
without doing this experiment which
saves you a lot of resources especially
when you think about
that in sbtf you're mainly dealing with
high concentrated protein solution which
is extremely expensive
so having a clever training data set and
avoiding all of these experiments saves
a lot of material especially in a phase
where you don't have that much material
if you think about
pre-clinical development you would need
several grams for this experiment and
you don't have it actually at you
this is this is something where you can
create a lot of value
because you just uh you just don't need
that much of it
of real
okay uh as said you could also think
about how you can then create your model
basically
you can think about if you want to have
a constant feed flow you can see how the
how the volumetric conversion factor
changes by your membranes
or if you want to understand better
basically you want to say okay i
i want to have a certain volumetric
conversion factor uh when i change the
membranes what would be my feed flow
so this can all be done in silicon so
you can definitely define your process
basically completely in silico
based on the single training data set as
mentioned already several times but
also if you think about process control
it adds in the same direction so you see
here for example two concentrations
uh if you think about changing something
in the upstream there might be a higher
lower title you could also interact with
this and if you use this model for
process control
think about for example how do i have to
change my my
uh my feed flow for example in order
to to achieve the same output
concentration so if you're at the end of
your spdf you want to have for example
25 grams per liter
how do i have to change my volumetric
conversion factor or my feed rate or my
factors in order to achieve this and
this is all intrinsic in a model
and therefore you could use these these
models already for process control
and it helps you quite a lot
yeah i said this would be defeat floats
for example if you want to change
between 10 and 4 grams
because if in upstream something changes
this would be the consequence
okay and here just some one slide also
for for parallel spf so
if you don't have a serial one but if
you have the parallel one also again we
changed something in the black box
sorry the experimental effort because
you cannot just do this with one
experiment
because you also have to change the
buffer somehow too in order to
understand this better
but also here again by closing this
hybrid by closing this modeling gap
uh if you are if you think about clever
ways to perform clever experiment get
the right data
have the right model structure in hand
here you can see for example in this dia
filtration use case
how the flux propagates over the
diaphragm volume as you see here
we changed 10 dire filtration volume
which took us 200 minutes and you can
see how the hybrid model is able to
predict the time
and also the the ph depending on the on
the
on the exchange volume it also helps you
for process control and for example to
define a certain
if you want to stop at a certain ph you
can definitely already know this from
the model
and the model can help you to for this
control
good finally summing all of this up uh
here in downstream data set
fine batch fed batch and sptff processes
so we need only a limited amount of
material
but we can predict in silicon the
duration of these processes
very accurately we could somehow
boost process understanding while
reducing the development times i said
and the prediction are extremely
accurate and the model can be used for
process control
on input changes okay so with this i
basically want to thank you for your
attention
if you want to connect you can always
either send me an email
or you could connect on linkedin for
example
or if you're interested i said in the
toolbox you can just use your phone now
and register
download the toolbox and directly use
the toolbox for your own
for your own showcases yeah this
i'm quite thankful to be part of nova
scion and yeah i would be happy to
connect to you
stay safe and and all the best thank you
bye
you